hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast robots in research
presented by Mike Simpson founder and
CEO one-world lab on Julie simmer off of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots is sponsored by
Buster Rio for more information about
our sponsor
visit foster bio calm before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
even is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click the green
Q&A button located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears in
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation for questions not
answered today we will follow up with
participants via email also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
icon located on the lower right of the
screen if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of the webpage and follow the process of
obtaining your credits please join me in
welcoming Mike Simpson I will now turn
the presentation over to him
the rise of the robots and indeed the
robots are coming frightened or not you
better be ready one of George Orwell's
famous quotes from his novel 1984 is who
controls the past controls the future
who controls the present controls the
past we're in a time in history where is
being rewritten with a frenetic pace as
new discoveries are being made an
accelerated pace in all disciplines the
philosopher tenets are kind of described
this time period as infinite novelty in
this book time wave zero so here we are
no other time in on history where so
much of the future is unpredictable
however in the future there is one thing
we can be certain about and that is
robots will become more integrated into
our lives so this presentation is
actually to show how the rise of robots
in research is going to be really
beneficial for Humanity and the day that
we see a bunch of blinking lights and
robots in our labs will be a great
advancement for science as to is that
I'm Mike Simpson founder and CEO of one
world lab one world lab has been a
distributor for a growing number of
antibody manufacturers over the past
five years with a new collaboration
between one world lab and HTS resources
a lab automation company we were able to
turn antibodies into micro arrays for
multi-plex athletes and so to do this
and our journey today I will show you
how we need automation in order to make
micro arrays I will present the
automation solutions we use for
recreating a non-contact dispensing of
biomolecules onto activated surfaces
like nitrocellulose with Pico leader
precision and array scanning the ability
to analyze the arrays with high
resolution throughput
and it has the ability to get ultra
sensitive detection I will also cover 3d
printing an additive
deposition technique used for rapid
prototyping and how we have used it to
innovate in the array printing business
as well as how it serves as the
framework for our lab I finally I will
cover how rap lab bots will enter our
lives through the Internet of Things and
end up saving us a tremendous amount of
time in the field of research these
programmable automated instruments are
the on the rise and my goal to show you
what it looks like and why we should
welcome this future so here and the
array printing that we will look at is
the gessen nano plotter which is the
system that we use desam is a german
company with a suite of automated
solutions for different applications and
the nano plotter is specifically unique
with its piezo electric pipette tips to
give it precise control over dispensing
of liquids it's fast and it has low CVS
between the inner and intro slide
printing it also has a very large
capacity slide that that can be chilled
heated and removed it has a stroboscope
that allows for flight detection of
droplets so in real time you can see
these little Pico liter amounts of
droplets touching the surface this
allows the fine-tuning and optimization
of the pipetting to get the desired
amount per spot their solenoid valve
dispensing which allows for larger
volumes of liquid to be dispensed for
applications that require and
accessories like the chiller and
humidifier are required in order to do
micro rate production this is the
workflow schematic that breaks down what
happens with the nano plotter it shows
that system fluid is used to aspirate up
the sample and then the chiesa electric
tip is used to dispense the sample into
these high density arrays if he has
electric tip is washed internally and
externally between runs even using the
piezo electric tip to Sonic 8 the tip
for additional
whosh value laser scanning that we use
is the key can power scanner and when
you printed out a large batch of arrays
what you want to do is scan those arrays
as quickly as possible the power scanner
is a high-capacity high throughput
system as the video explains it allows
us to process 48 slides simultaneously
more importantly is that it can do this
quickly with proprietary high-speed data
transmission with the two fluorescence
detection at the redshifted side three
and sci-fi channels so we have a dual
detection system that goes down to a two
micron resolution using a dual PMT for
additional sensitivity now remember that
each spot is about 100 microns in
diameter so a 2 micron resolution that's
50 pixels per spot which is incredible
sensitivity the suggested amount of
pixels needed to analyze with confidence
is 10 pixels so you can see that the
system can go above and beyond what is
required and depending upon your
application you have the flexibility to
go even down to lower ranges of
detection using a 16-bit imaging system
that has a gain which ranges from point
1 to 1000 which allows you to increase
single intensity at log 5 scale so you
look at the laser scanning what it does
is that this high-end piece of equipment
captures the images of the fluorescent
dots it's able to measure the intensity
that the fluorescence intensity and
convert it into a numerical value which
can be interpolated into a standard
curve and used to quantify biomarkers
and samples these are all
state-of-the-art devices that we use to
do our microarray service and create
microarrays and each one cost 150
thousand
to be able to implement in your lab so
it's a very huge capital expense to
overcome for a start-up company and as a
startup company we're always looking for
more affordable solutions to be
innovative to be able to manufacture and
produce things cheaply and that is where
3d printing has come to create the third
Industrial Revolution and open hardware
rapid prototyping machine approach which
allows us to cheaply and quickly do 3d
printing or rapid prototyping of
different devices and the the types of
3d printing out we're talking about here
is RepRap so RepRap is a more
open-source software and hardware
platform that has this concept that one
of these RepRap 3d printers can
reproduce itself and while this isn't
not entirely true it is very affordable
in order to create lab equipment to try
out different devices to replace pieces
of equipment that you have to buy all
this can be done with a 3d printer in
fact this is being used at the consumer
level where a family that uses a 3d
printer to replace just 20 household
items in a year could save up to $2,000
and we've taken this approach and one
specific application which is the arrays
so we've been able to use 3d printing to
reverse engineer the nitrocellulose
slides that we typically are using so
the price from one nitrocellulose slide
is about $30 by creating a slide casting
station that allows us to code a mono
layer the agarose on a slide so that we
can do the same assay but with the
surface that cost pennies to the dollar
you can see how we use the casting
station with the clips and to run this
assay later scanned it to prove that you
can get the same precision in spot
placement is proof that you can do this
type of innovation strapping prototyping
and
juice very valuable data quickly and
affordably the next thing that is on the
rise and within really 3d printing and
in relation to that is the file printing
so 3d printing and creating bio
scaffolding is a very hot area it's
becoming more and more popular and in
orthopedics there's a substrate called
flex bone they can be printed into a
matrix which can fit into a void of a
bone it stimulates the regeneration of
new bones with hydroxyapatite while
releasing antibiotics to prevent
infections this is being used for
generating vasculature and organs de
novo right now so people are printing
out veins and little livers using the
same type of technique so this is
shaping the future as we know it then
there's no way that this could be done
without the use of automation and robots
to create these tightly interwoven
biological matrices so everything that
I've talked about the technology I've
really spoken about this bar is robotics
automation that is being able to provide
value and labs across the world and in
our lab as well and the hottest startups
right now are manufacturing robotics
solutions to to help in the
manufacturing processes in all
industries and they're all incorporating
the Internet of Things for ultimate
connectivity efficiency and
functionality so here's a diagram of the
Internet of Things which is simply the
connecting of devices to hopefully
create human value so the internet
serves as the network that connects
these devices we are using note is the
note read as programming languages that
connect our device to the Internet and
these devices can be monitored anywhere
with the appropriate web address the
device what it does is it captures data
so the robot would be analyzing data
sending that information that
data to another database for analysis so
can then have the database or what other
connected software to send instructions
back based on the analysis to the device
so the device can continue doing what
it's doing it can change its operation
or stop entirely what it is doing based
on the command so for us humans in these
efficiencies and traceability throughout
an entire process like we've never
experienced before and here we see the
lab lot 3d what richard routes that HTS
resources is done is absolutely
extraordinary
richard is an inventor engineer
programmer biologist who is reverse
engineered many of the features and
functions of instruments i presented
earlier into the lab bought 3d seen here
in an animated gif he has invented his
own proprietary method for
high-throughput scanning and data
capture that replaces the power scanner
he has reverse engineered the piezo
electric system for doing pico liter
dispensing but his own stroboscope
technology for real-time droplet
detection replacing the nano plotter
completely since the lab by 3d is built
on RepRap framework it can also
incorporate a module for 3d printing so
that you can now use it as a bio printer
and as you can see from the animated gif
it has a moving slide bed conveyor
system that gives it a higher throughput
capacity than the nano plotter which
takes up twice as much space so looking
at a little bit more of the details of
lab bot 3d you see it does have all the
functionality of the eye and equipment
but it's contained all in one robot so
the footprint here is a fist inside of a
3 foot by 3 foot space and again has
greater capacity than the nano plotter
to do larger batch runs and even has
more resolution and innovation in the
motorized conveying
edge system and that those motors rely
on a quart XY motion with linear
encoders for feedback which allow for
microns depth resolution again the spots
that it is making are about 100 micron
in dynamic diameter and the motors can
move in 2.5 microns steps x and y or
1.25 micron steps up and down in the
z-axis that's incredible
there's innovation in the syringe pump
and the three-way valve to add another
level of precision in the liquid
aspiration and dispensing so the goal is
a Pico leader ability to control your
solution your precious biomolecules is
enhanced in this robot and of course
it's connected to the internet of things
so that you can notify via Twitter when
your robot should start and stop and it
can then communicate to you when it has
completed a run finished analyzing
samples and needs to order more reagents
so here we have additional resources the
most important innovation here is
affordability instead of hundreds of
thousands of dollars to get started this
lab bought 3d cost a few tens of
thousands of dollars and replaces the
need for several pieces of equipment
that require additional maintenance
costs so this is revolutionary for small
companies and academic labs to be able
to start using automation and save a
tremendous amount of time and cost learn
more about the lab bots 3d please visit
the HTS resources website listed here to
become involved in this community please
visit the san diego robots and research
meetup group and then if you are
interested in ordering products you can
visit arrays 1.1 road lab calm and what
I'd like to summarize is that you know
through all of this technology that we
are using today and what I'm showing you
how it is improving
we can agree it means to have what it
means to have robots and research it
will mean that world's brightest minds
are no longer consumed with the menial
tasks of pipetting blotting and scanning
there will be a loud bot to take care of
basic lab routine analyze data and order
products the bright minds can now spend
time on critical thinking expanding
projects and networks in solving complex
biological problems that can save lives
thank you again I'm Mike Simpson and
feel free to contact me regarding any
information presented here thank you
Mike for that formative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question we will follow up with you via
email after the presentation let's get
started the first question is what
operating systems does the lab bot 3d
have new system and so we're just
running on a Bluetooth and allows for us
to not deal with licenses or really
allow for more of a collaborative
framework to do it again and really
encourage more developers to build out
applications on the operating system
great thank you
the next question is where can i buy one
3ds are being developed at HTS resources
and through our collaboration I can be
contacted you can directly reach out to
Richard at HTS resources for information
or work with me in order to get a quote
which of course the other will wrap up
with one last question and that is do
you have any patents around the movement
on the conveyor system the slide bed
system there stats on the the way that
there's an algorithm for scanning the
slide detecting the the signal and then
converting that intensity into a
numerical value for quantification so
those are all patents but several more
that have kind of waiting to be filed
but there's definitely a lot of
innovative technology with a few patents
behind the moment I would like to once
again thank Mike for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots in
foster bio for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 24th
2017 you will receive an email from lab
reaps letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye